c'est demain que s'ouvrira en
saône-et-loire le procès d'un vaste
réseau pédophile ou comparaître en
soixante et une personnes l'explosion
d'internet un peu partout dans le monde
inquiète au point que le fbi a il devant
l'ampleur du phénomène à créer un
service spécialisé où les agents se font
passer pour des enfants pour confondre
les criminels notre correspondant
permanent aux états unis etienne
leenhardt
depuis deux ans dans ce petit pavillon
d'une banlieue de houston chéri glover
et sa fille tente d'oublier folle
d'internet kate avait 12 ans lorsque
dans un de ces forums de discussion
appelé chat elle rencontra si l'on peut
dire un certain charlie lui lisait avoir
16 ans
ont discuté simplement de ce qui se
passe dans la société de ce qui se passe
à l'école de ce qui se passe en ville
il était amoureux il voulait se marier
vous savez j'ai pensé elle a 12 ans un
vieux fantasme alors j'ai laissé faire
en plus lui il est tellement loin
charlie n'avait pas 16 mai 36 ans marié
père de quatre enfants il est
aujourd'hui en prison dans son agenda la
police retrouvera des photos de kate nue
qu'elle avait accepté de prendre
d'elle-même dans le secret de sachant
que les parents se disent à la maison
rien peut t'arriver aux enfants a pas
d'alcool pas de drogue et d'armes ils ne
peuvent pas tomber enceinte
elle croit que sous leur toit il n'y a
plus de raison d'avoir peur
les risques sont d'autant plus grands
enfants et adolescents peuvent parfois
se retrouver sur des sites inattendue
whitehouse.gov par exemple et le site
officiel de la maison blanche mais si
par mégarde l'on tape white house points
comme on se retrouve sur un site
pornographique depuis quatre ans de jour
comme de nuit une unité spécialisée du
fbi y ait rate les pédophiles des
inspecteurs comme michael se font passer
pour des enfants étant d'organiser des
rendez-vous pour confondre les criminels
n'imaginez pas que ce sont de vieux os a
dit cox m dans les parcs en général ce
sont des docteurs des avocats il nous
est arrivé d'arrêter un policier des
conducteurs de bus des instituteurs
c'est vraiment effrayant
ce travail qui exige des policiers une
connaissance parfaite du langage utilisé
par les enfants commencent à payer
depuis trois ans plus de 400 pédophiles
naviguant sur internet ont été arrêtés
et condamnés aux états unis